MPs attempts to stop no deal next week
depend on a small group of conservative
back benches if they rebel against their
government Boris Johnson could well be
defeated but the price of rebellion
could be there political careers in
Westminster the group which includes a
number of former ministers is known as
the gore quid squad so it's fitting that
we're joined by the former justice
secretary David gorg very good morning
to you look just to clarify in all of
this in terms of this suspension this
prorogation of parliament is there
anything illegal or unconstitutional
about it I think some of the language is
has been a little over the top and I
think this constitutes a coup but I do
think it's wrong I think we are entering
into a period which is crucial for this
country we have got big decisions to
make and the government should be
scrutinized by Parliament's who say
whether that's the preparations for no
deal or the attempts to reach a deal
Parliament should be scrutinizing what
the government is doing in Parliament
needs to be sitting to do that and in
fact I think Parliament should be
sitting more days over the next few
weeks than it would normally do not
fewer so I think it is wrong to have
suspended Parliament for that five-week
period I mean I know this is a matter in
front of the courts it may well be that
legally the government is entitled to do
so but I think as a matter of judgment
Parliament should be sitting throughout
September and October given the
particular circumstances that we're in
yet that wasn't going to be the case as
far as we understood it conference
season is under way I mean the message
from from number 10 is actually this is
only affecting four or five days of
Parliament sitting I think the
likelihood is that given a widespread
sense that Parliament should be sitting
during these crucial weeks in late
September and early October I think the
likelihood is that Parliament would have
sought to ensure that there were extra
days that Parliament was sitting during
the conference recess period and one of
the reasons why I think the government
has done that is to close that
possibility off and I do think the in
our system whereby government is held to
account where ministers are held to
account by Parliament that's what should
happen I was a minister for nine years I
know it can be frustrating to be held to
account by Parliament but that is part
of the job and that's what should be
happening over the course of the next
few weeks is there an argument to be
made it is being made and you will have
heard it many times that says in all of
this we've had this huge democratic
process of which Parliament agreed that
they would listen to the will of the
people nothing's happened in three years
you've not been able to agree with drol
agreement in the House of Commons if
Boris Johnson did not take this action
to you know ultimately hinder people
trying to stop as leaving with a No Deal
brexit the in fact we'd end up just
remaining we wouldn't be able to enforce
the will of the people well first of all
I regret the fact that Parliament did
not support the withdrawal agreement I
voted for it three times had my way
prevailed we would have left the
European Union what five months ago so
I'm not someone who is wanting to
frustrate the referendum result I want
us to leave the European Union but I
want us to do so with a deal because
without that as you know frankly our
departure will be very different from
the prospectus that was put to the
British people in the 2016 referendum
campaign where what was said is that we
will be able to leave in a smooth and
orderly way we would have a deal we
wouldn't have tariffs and quotas we'd be
able to trade with the European Union
just as we have done up until now a No
Deal brexit if we're looking at the
substance will be a very different
nature and it will have an impact on
people's jobs and livelihoods living
standards our security and I think the
integrity of the United Kingdom because
I think it will encourage for example
Northern Ireland to unite with the
Republic of Ireland and all courage
separatists in Scotland so this is a
very very bad outcome for the country
and I don't think it has a mandate from
the 2016 referendum and I don't think it
should happen unless Parliament consents
to it you could be seeing the Prime
Minister tomorrow well I think it's been
reported there are there is a meeting
that is trees
I will have an opportunity to speak to
the Prime Minister tomorrow and to say
what well I want to hear from him as to
what his his plan to deliver a deal when
are we putting forward proposals to deal
with this backstop issue which is the
the one issue he has identified as the
problem within the withdrawal agreement
I want to hear how he's going to address
that and I want to hear how he's plans
to deliver the legislation if we get a
deal by the 31st of October because I at
the moment frankly I can't see how he's
got time to do that this is where we end
up in a whole world of contradiction
though isn't it in the sense that you
say you want to see a deal you want us
you want to hear from the Prime Minister
tomorrow how he's going to achieve a
deal there is an argument to be made
that says if you then try to thwart a no
deal breaks in as many people are trying
to do in which he appears to be trying
to avoid then you actually stop him
getting a deal now I don't agree with
that I think it is worth looking what
are the things that are stopping us
getting a deal first of all everybody
agrees that there shouldn't be a hard
border between Northern Ireland and the
Republic of Ireland but given our plans
in terms of leaving customs union and so
on
and you know we need to find a practical
way to ensure that a hard border isn't
necessary now Boris Johnson doesn't like
the plans and withdrawal agreements on
that ass but he if he's got an
alternative then he should put that
forward and if he's got an alternative
that is workable I will fully support it
and I will vote for it but first of all
we need to have those plans second we
need to have a realistic plan to get the
legislation through the House of Commons
we've got to have the time and we've
also got to make sure that some of my
colleagues don't say well it's not just
the backstop it's something else and
we're still not gonna support it and I
think you know this idea that the threat
of no deal is going to make the European
Union member states move dramatically
I'm afraid I think is a bit of a fantasy
the European Union member states know
that no deal will have a bigger impact
on us than it will on them I think we
just have to face facts about that and
they are not going to move
their positions so that we end up with
needing a hard order between Northern
Ireland and the Republic okay so on the
basis that you're not gonna which is
unlikely that you're gonna hear anything
from the Prime Minister that's going to
completely satisfy you tomorrow what are
the plans for the coming week auu what
can you do to try to work and legislate
within Parliament to stop this No Deal
happening well I don't want to get into
too many details about us there's
obviously quite a lot of speculation
about it about seizing the order paper
and then taking legislation through my
view is that it is important that
Parliament is not excluded from this
process and that we shouldn't be it
shouldn't allow the government just to
sort of run the clock down and take us
out without a deal and I fear that that
is the direction that we're going in I
think it would be with respect you say
you don't want to get into too much
detail but in fact we it's the detail
that people need on this isn't it are
you going to try and in effect force
through an extension well I think the
detail will become very apparent in the
next few days but I think the important
thing is the Parliament should not be
excluded from this process as I say I
don't believe that
No Deal has a mandate from the 2016
referendum I don't think it's got the
support of Parliament but I think
Parliament does have to be still part of
this process and I don't think it should
be excluded and the problem is that if
we don't act in this week I think it's
likely that Parliament will be excluded
from this process firstly I would have
been happier to have left this for
another few weeks let's see how the
negotiations were progressing let's see
the government's plans on this but the
fact is that now that Parliament is
essentially only going to be sitting
this week and then by the time we come
back in in mid-october it will be too
late for Parliament to take any
effective action to prevent no deal so
the choice for Parliament seems to be
very clear if it's going to take action
it needs to take action in the next few
days when we talk about the the goal
quadsquad
as it were it seems like you you you
haven't got a clear-eyed
exactly want what you want to achieve in
the time that you do have available well
from my perspective I want us to leave
with a deal I think that is a better
outcome than either failing to deliver
the referendum result or leaving or what
action are you going to take to stop as
leaving without a date on October 31st
well that I think will become clearer as
we set out the legislation this week
assuming that we get the votes to to
take it if you get if you get out if you
get those votes or as you say but I mean
our effective the people will look at
this and say well the only real option
is to to force the prime minister to
apply for an extension well I think if
we are not ready to leave because we
haven't got a deal on the 31st of
October then we shouldn't leave on the
31st of October that's absolutely right
I think you know we we do have to
demonstrate or we've you know we may
well need to be flexible on this if we
can get a deal by the 31st of October
the prime minister comes back and he's
got legislation you can get through in
that time I will support it I'm not sure
that every Conservative MP can say that
but I will certainly support him if he
gets a if he gets a deal but if he
doesn't get a deal the responsible
course of action would be to extend
article 50 and seek to address these
issues and the foot in the time
afterwards so you are in that sense you
are pretty well aligned with with labour
and with what Kirsten has put forward
well I I believe that the right course
of action is to get a deal or and that's
where there is perhaps a difference with
me in the Labor Party and I've
consistently voted for a deal whereas
the Labour Party by and large has
opposed it but do I think the
responsible course of action is to leave
without a deal on the 31st of October
now I don't are you prepared to lose the
party whip on this because their reports
in the paper today that those
Conservative MPs who rebel could lose
the whip are you prepared to do that
well I've seen those reports I mean if
it is the position now that you know
defying a whip on a European vote is a
matter that you lose the
that the whip for the Conservative Party
then I think there's quite a lot of
conservative MPs who over the recent
months would have lost the the whip but
you know sometimes there is a point
where it is you have to judge between
your own personal interests and the
national interest and the national
interests has to come first but I hope
it doesn't come to that and I hope that
cooler and calmer heads will look at
this and think that trying to split the
Conservative Party in this way is not a
sensible way forward for the
Conservative Party or indeed for the
country one of your colleagues Oliver
latwon has said you know in effect
time isn't the issue here when it comes
to sorting this out it's getting a
majority that would them about this if
that doesn't happen and you don't get
this true where you would you then look
at supporting a vote of no confidence in
the government if that is brought
forward by the Labour Party well the
position I've consistently said is that
you know the country faces two big risks
a crash out on the 31st of October or a
Jeremy Corbyn government I don't want to
do anything that would facilitate a
Jeremy Corbyn government indeed one of
my worries about a No Deal brexit is
that it will create the chaos in which
Jeremy Corbyn could win a general
election so I I don't want him to become
Prime Minister but isn't that part of
the argument that some people would say
well you you say you want to do
everything to stop a No Deal brexit but
you're not prepared to do that
to support him getting into number 10
even if just for a very short period of
time I don't believe that Jeremy Corbyn
is fit to be Prime Minister and I don't
want to facilitate that okay David go up
very good to talk to you this morning
thank you very much indeed